hi there steve kaufman here
i haven't
done these in a while so i felt like
doing this evening
a question that i'm often asked is do i
worry or do i make mistakes or do i
confuse
languages that are similar mandarin and
cantonese italian spanish portuguese and
so forth
well the answer is that i probably do
the
weaker languages tend to get
interference from the stronger languages
so my cantonese will have mandarin in it
my portuguese will have spanish in it my
italian will have spanish in it
but
i don't worry about it
because i would rather be able to speak
three languages with mistakes
than speak one language with no mistakes
in any case i can't speak one language
with no mistakes so it really does
bother me knowing related languages
helps you to speak those languages even
with the odd bit of of mixture it's just
not a problem in my opinion
and you know i i'm going to say a little
bit more about this issue of of errors
uh
because i was you know i'm preparing uh
an ebook of my blog i've had my blog now
the linguist on language
for over five years and i've selected
some of my posts over these five years
and
put them into a book
and i've been working on it for the last
uh you know a little while
and
part of my blog posts or some of my blog
posts have been with reference to books
that i have read so therefore i've gone
back and reread some of these books or
at least leave through them
one of these books was a book called
second nature
brain science and human knowledge
by gerald edelman who is also a nobel
prize winner in medicine
and
i'm not sure i fully understand the book
gerald edelman has a background in
immunology and the
sort of selectionist response of our of
our immune system
uh to various uh you know viruses and so
forth and he takes that into his
analysis of the brain and how the
neurons
all however many billion of them there
are
in our
three pound brain how they
respond in a sort of selectionist way to
all of the tremendous
stimulus impulse experience information
that the brain gets deluged with
and he makes the point that in order to
cope with all this information the brain
deals with
comparisons
things that are similar metaphors he
says in other words it tries to look for
patterns
and in doing so it's able to cope with
all this information but by the same
token it's not able to be precise or
logical so i think that's a very
important point we have to accept error
as a part of of
dealing with this tremendous amount of
information and when we are dealing with
a language we're dealing with a
tremendous amount of information many
many words many combinations of words
and so
it is better for us to absorb all this
input the words the phrases look for
similarities look for patterns rather
than to try to come up with
precision error proof production of the
language so
you know just his analysis of how the
brain works kind of confirms
my approach to language my approach is
more many much varied rather than
precision
and
you know this evening uh you know i was
just thinking i went out for dinner
because my wife went off to toronto and
i didn't want to cook
so i took with me my book i'm reading a
portuguese a brazilian book
written in portuguese
i can't remember what it's called
actually but it takes place
it begins in
in sao paulo where the writer of the
book meets with this
older japanese lady who tells him a
story that took place in japan
so the bulk of the book so far takes
place in japan but i'm reading it in
portuguese
the book started
in brazil and the
first person in the book although i
don't think the author is but the first
person in the book is a brazilian of
japanese origin
so i'm reading this book
and as i read the book about japan
i have this tremendous longing to read
some japanese literature because there
is that certain
quality of quiet and stillness
which
may not be representative of life in
japan it is as it is today
but it is representative of some of the
most attractive aspects of japanese
culture
literature architecture
uh nature and so forth
so through the japanese book
my desire now to maybe the next book i
grab will be a japanese book so that
stimulated my interest
in the restaurant where i was sitting
it so happened that the owner is french
and
the next the
they share this patio with the japanese
restaurant
and i happen to know that the japanese
restaurant is run by a korean and his
partner
a korean canadian and his partner used
to be a japanese canadian
and
sitting there is this family that i take
to be some kind of middle eastern i
don't know if they're armenian or
lebanese or what they are persian maybe
and they're all eating with chopsticks
and they're eating japanese food
so all i'm saying is that there is so
much variety
in terms of human culture food language
experience
and the more of it we can experience
and take part in
the better and all of that is much more
important than
nailing down little bits of grammar
or how you're supposed to hold the
chopstick or whether you bow with your
left side of the head or the right side
all this other
detail
it doesn't really matter in my view
so really
today i didn't have much to say other
than we can't be
we can't be free of error we're going to
be
committing errors in our in our
discovery of languages
the brain
has us preconditioned to make mistakes
because our brain is looking for
similarities comparisons metaphors and
and in order to cope with this
tremendous amount of information there's
tremendous variety
the brain is structured in such a way as
to sacrifice accuracy
and that's good so we may as well
enjoy it i don't know if any of
all of this
makes sense uh i might add that the
weather here in vancouver has been
awesome the last little while
uh
the sun has been warm much warmer than
usual
and that i have been enjoying swimming
in the ocean and kayaking and with my
son and grandson we dropped some crab
traps but we didn't catch any crabs
uh and we're just enjoying the summer so
the main thing is
just enjoy
thanks for listening bye for now